good morning Hank it's Wednesday I'm in
Venice and I'm really sick but I don't
want to talk about other of those things
I want to talk about the evil baby
orphanage and our first president George
Washington Brett so Hank as I'm sure you
recall a few years ago nerdfighters came
up with the idea that instead of like
going back in a time machine and killing
evil people when they're babies we could
go back and kidnap them and take them to
the evil baby orphanage where you know
we could rehabilitate them I think it's
obviously a fantastic idea aside from
the small problem of you know time
travel being quite challenging but
here's my question Hank how do you
decide who is a good candidate for the
evil baby orphanage take for example
George Washington terrible evil baby
orphanage candidate right like you
thought the British in the war for
independence he was a huge part of the
American Constitution represented
democracy wooden teeth six foot eight
way too fricking ton all that stuff he
was also an arguably really good at
being the American president but hey
what if our nearly universal assumption
that the American Revolution was a good
thing is wrong like let's say we kidnap
George Washington as a baby and take
them to the evil baby orphanage how if
at all does that change history turns
out to be a pretty interesting question
let's assume although I think this is a
bit dubious that somehow we're moving
George Washington from history causes us
to lose and or not fight the
Revolutionary War the probably takes the
United States at least seventy more
years to achieve its independence like
let's assume that we're following the
Canada model but we still eventually end
up with the representative democracy and
a court following the Canada model some
excellent beer furthermore as pointed
out in MD Anderson's brilliant novel the
astonishing life of Octavian nothing the
Revolutionary War was decidedly a bad
thing for the people who most needed the
protection of a government the slaves
and Hank it's almost certain that
slavery would have ended earlier in
America if we had just remained a
British colony furthermore heck it's not
totally unreasonable to assume that with
slavery ending in the early 19th century
at some point we might have avoided the
Civil War which was the bloodiest
conflict in the United States history
resulting in 600,000 dead people but it
doesn't stop there Hank because we all
know that one of the key factors in the
French Revolution was the France
bankrupted itself helping us fight our
revolution now Mike I'm not saying that
George Washington knew by the way was a
slave owner is responsible for a century
of slavery or 600,000 dead people I'm
just saying that as usual the truth
resists simplicity so Hank here's by a
non rhetorical question for the day how
do we know who's a good candidate for
the evil baby orphanage given the
complexity of history and more
importantly how do
we know that we ourselves are not living
lives that could result in us going to
the evil baby orphanage let's continue
the conversation and comments and in
your pants Hank I'll see you on Friday